♪ ♪
>> Greg: ONE OF DANA'S
FAVORITE SONGS.
SOMETHING WEIRD IS HAPPENING IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I MEAN MORE THAN THE USUAL
WEIRD.
THIS IS A GOOD WEIRD.
THE WHINY KIDS HAVE MADE SO MUCH
OF A RACKET THAT THE ADULTS ARE
FINALLY WAKING UP.
FIRST, BET BOB JOHNSON SAYS THIS
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS.
"THE PARTY IN MY OPINION HAS
MOVED FOR ME PERSONALLY TOO FAR
TO THE LEFT.
AND FOR THAT REASON, I DON'T
HAVE A CANDIDATE IN THIS
PARTICULAR PARTY AT THIS TIME.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY,
IF A DEMOCRAT IS GOING TO BEAT
TRUMP, THAT PERSON HE OR SHE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE TO THE
CENTER.
AND YOU CAN'T WAIT TOO LONG TO
DO THAT."
>> Greg: HE SAID THIS ABOUT
THE ECONOMY.
>> I THINK THE ECONOMY IS DOING
AN ABSOLUTELY GREAT.
SO AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT
IS AT ITS LOWEST LEVEL, HISPANIC
UNEMPLOYMENT, WOMEN, SO I GIVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I HAVE SAID
THIS BEFORE, I GIVE THE
PRESIDENT A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
REMOVING THE ECONOMY AND A
POSITIVE DIRECTION THAT HAS BEEN
A LARGE NUMBER OF AMERICANS.
>> Greg: THAT SOUND YOU HEAR
IS CORY BOOKER CRYING.
AND THEN THERE IS JEH JOHNSON
COME OBAMA SECRETARY CRITICIZING
HIS PARTY'S CANDIDATE FOR
ESSENTIALLY PROCLAIMING TO
SMUGGLERS THAT WE HAVE OPEN
BORDERS.
WOW, WHERE DID THESE GUYS COME
FROM?
A MAGA RALLY?
SO I APPLAUD THIS BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THE SENSIBLE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS IN HIDING,
TERRIFIED OF THE VOICES AND
UNLIKABLE MESS OF IDENTITIES
GRAMMARS THAT SYMPATHIZERS WHO
THROW MILK SHAKES FOR EXERCISE.
MAYBE THESE TWO JOHNSONS WILL
LEAD THE WAY FOR OTHERS TO STAND
UP AND SHOUT STOPPING CRAZY.
THE BULLY -- IF ONLY PEOPLE
WOULD LISTEN.
BUT RIGHT NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE
APPROACHING COLD STATUS.
ONE THAT REJECTS ALL
MAINSTREAMING SHRINKING IN SIZE
AS THEY ALIENATE EVERYONE WHO
ISN'T WOKEN UP.
FOR THE NEW LEFT, ANY DEVIATION
FROM RESIST MAKES YOU COMPLICIT
AND EVIL JUST BEEN BORN TO MAKE
A RACIST.
BUT THIS STRATEGY IS FOR LOSERS
MEANING IF ONLY FOUR PEOPLE BY
YOUR TINY LITTLE DEFINITION OR
WOKE THAT MEANS THE REMAINING
340 MILLION AREN'T.
IF YOU WISH TO CONDONE --
CONDEMN THE UNWELCOME TO SAY
GOODBYE TO ALL OF THEM.
YOU WILL BE THE WORLD'S SMALLEST
PARTY ONE THAT NO ONE WANTS TO
ATTEND.
YOU KNOW, DANA, IF I WERE A TEAM
SPORT, I WOULD HAVE TRASHED THE
JOHNSONS, RIGHT?
I DON'T WANT THE DEMS TO LIST
THEM.
I WANT THEM TO KEEP GOING.
AND THE IDENTITY PATH BUT I AM A
GOOD PERSON.
I'M ALMOST AS GOOD AS ED HENRY.
HE IS DONATING HIS LIVER.
I'M DONATING MY THOUGHTS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SPEAK TO THEM BEFORE THE SHOW,
WE GOT AN UPDATE THAT ED CAME
THROUGH THE SURGERY AND DID JUST
FINE.
>> Greg: I THINK MY SUPPORT
GOT HIM THROUGH.
>> Katie: I CANNOT WAIT UNTIL
HE'S WELL ENOUGH TO LAUGH AGAIN.
HE WILL BE WATCHING.
SO THE JEH JOHNSON I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING BECAUSE HE WAS LIKE
STOP.
WHEN HE DID IT WAS RIGHT AFTER
THE DEMOCRATIC DEBATE WHEN ALL
BUT ONE OR TWO PEOPLE RAISED
THEIR HAND SAYING THEY WERE FOR
DECRIMINALIZING CROSSINGS AT THE
BORDER.
AND FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO WIN ALL THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTES, BUT IF
HE CAN INCREASE HIS MERCHANT
JUST A LITTLE BIT, THAT WILL
HELP.
REMEMBER, THAT BO DID NOT TURN
OUT AS WELL AS FOR
HILLARY CLINTON AS BARACK OBAMA.
SO THAT IS AN AREA WHERE I THINK
THAT THE REPUBLICANS CAN MAKE
SOME GAINS IF THEY WANT TO FOCUS
A LITTLE BIT.
>> Greg: JESSE, CAN YOU NAME
THE CITY THAT JOHNSON WAS SAND?
>> Jesse: WAS IT TYREE?
>> Greg: IT MIGHT BE EITHER
THAT OR VEGAS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: YOU NEVER KNOW.
AND SOMETHING THAT I SAID TWO OR
THREE TIMES ALREADY IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT,
YOU CAN'T WIN THE GENERAL WITH
SOCIALISM AND YOU CAN'T WIN THE
PRIMARY WITHOUT IT.
HERE IS THE CONUNDRUM, 60% OF
AMERICANS OPPOSE GIVING HEALTH
INSURANCE TO ILLEGALS.
60% OPPOSE ELIMINATING PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE.
60% OPPOSE REPARATIONS AND
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OPPOSE GUN
SANCTUARY CITIES.
BUT THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
LEFT-WING VOTERS SUPPORT ALL
THAT STUFF.
SO THERE IS A HUGE DISCONNECT
BETWEEN MAINSTREAM CONSENSUS
AMERICAN THINKING AND DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY VOTERS THAT PUTS THEM IN
A HUGE BLIND.
NOTICE HOW THEY HAVE TABLED THE
TRADITIONAL BREAD AND BUTTER,
KITCHEN TABLE ISSUES, LIKE JOBS,
WAGES, TRADE, MANUFACTURING
BECAUSE THE TRUMP ECONOMY IS SO
HOT.
AND ALL OF THE MASS OF WAGE
GROWTH IS TAKING PLACE AMONGST
THE BOTTOM HALF OF WAGE EARNERS,
ESPECIALLY AMONG BLACKS AND
HISPANICS.
IT IS THE BOTTOM UP RECOVERY AS
OPPOSED TO THE OBAMA PAIUTE FOR
COVERAGE MOSTLY FROM THE TOP.
TO DANA'S POINT, THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO RECREATE
THAT OBAMA COALITION.
HILLARY COULDN'T DO IT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO REPLICATE IT
AGAIN.
MINORITIES, YOUNG WOMEN,
MILLENNIALS, THEY ARE JUST NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO IT.
SO I JUST THINK TRUMP SCOTT THIS
WALKED DOWN TO THE MAX AND
BARRING AN UNFORESEEN, IT IS
REELECTION IN A LANDSLIDE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE ONE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT TALKED ABOUT THE
NEED FOR A CENTER LANE AND STUFF
LIKE THAT.
THE PROBLEM IS, THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE IN THE CENTER
OR WIGGLING OUT OF IT.
THEY SHOULD BE LIKE THE
JOHNSON'S AND SAY, WE WANT THE
CENTER LANE.
>> Jesse: THE JOHNSON'S.
>> Greg: THE JOHNSON'S.
WE NEED A BAND-AID FROM
JOHNSON & JOHNSON.
>> Juan: I CAN GET THEM
TOGETHER.
I WILL SAY, I THOUGHT YOUR
ANALYSIS WAS PRETTY GOOD.
THE CONUNDRUM, BUT THE THING IS,
JESSE IT'S A DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
YOU HAVE TO GET THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION.
>> Jesse: I KNOW.
>> Juan: THIS IS NO
COORDINATION A COMPLAINT BY
HILLARY CLINTON IF YOU WILL
RECALL.
YOU HAVE REAL FACTIONS IN THE
PARTY CONTESTING TO SEE WHO
COMES OUT ON TOP.
I THINK THAT IS HEALTHY BUT LET
ME JUST SAY --
>> Greg: HAS IT MOVED TO THE
LEFT, JUAN, COME ON.
>> Juan: GIVE ME A SECOND.
I THINK THE YOUNG PEOPLE, GREG,
ARE PUSHING TO THE LEFT.
BUT GUESS WHAT, JOE BIDEN
REMAINS IN THE LEAGUE AND THE
DEMOCRATIC RACE.
WHY IS THAT?
THE OLDER FOLKS, AND GUESS WHAT,
THE BLACKS AND HISPANIC BACK
JOE BIDEN.
>> Greg: I'M TOAST SO TIRED OF
GUESSING.
>> Juan: MAY BE THE PARTY HAS
NOT MOVED SO FAR TO THE LEFT TO
MY MIND.
THE REPUBLICANS UNDER TRUMP HAVE
MOVED TO THE FAR LEFT.
>> Juan: I THINK THEIR
POLITICS REFLECTING WHAT THEY
ARE EXPERIENCING ESPECIALLY IN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WHERE
YOU HAVE FAMILIES SEPARATED.
>> Greg: SEPARATING THE
FAMILIES AGAIN, KATIE.
>> Katie: OH, MY GOSH, THAT
OLD THING.
THIS IS A REFLECTION OF THE
DEMOCRATS SAYING EVERYTHING
UNDER TRUMP IS A CRISIS AND
THEREFORE NOTHING IS A CRISIS.
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE BOB
JOHNSON AND JEH JOHNSON COMING
OUT COMPLETELY DESTROYS THE
ARGUMENT THAT DONALD TRUMP IS A
RACIST AND HAS TO BE STOPPED AT
ALL COST REGARDLESS OF ALL THE
OTHER ECONOMIC FACTORS WERE
POLICY POSITIONS.
PEOPLE LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN, I
WILL SAY, IS PUTTING FORWARD A
POLICY POSITION WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME GOING AFTER TRUMP VERY
PERSONALLY.